Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata
di Cucina Buttata, oggi faremo una delle
cose che dall'inizio di questo format
io sogno di potervi riproporre. Solamente
che prima bisognava ovviamente fare delle
cose un pochino più famose, è arrivato
però il momento di fare una ricetta che,
tra parentesi, mi è pure stata
consigliata un paio di volte, diciamo pure più di
un paio di volte, perché là fuori è pieno
di intenditori, mica come questi due che me l'hanno
sconsigliato in tutti i modi. Sto
parlando dei mochi giapponesi - Buuu (Enrico)
- Sei abituato tu a questo suono vero?
Comunque che cosa sono i mochi? I mochi
sono questi dolcettini, questi fagottini
di una pasta di riso un pochino gommosina
ripieni solitamente di marmellate
varie, confetture. Ora io ricordo, mi viene
in mente quella ai fagioli che fanno i
giapponesi. Infatti sono gli unici dolci
giapponesi che fanno scoraggiare. Una
variante di cui io sono innamorato
follemente è quella dei mochi ripieni in
realtà di gelato, oggi faremo dei mochi
alla vaniglia ma la cosa figa è che
potrete utilizzare il gelato che
preferite. Quando sono figo che oggi sto
continuando a guardare a sinistra e a
destra come se fosse in tv? Buuu. Per fare i mochi
avevamo bisogno di amido di mais
zucchero, acqua, mochiko. Questo è vitale, ho
fatto un pochino di ricerche ho visto
che in Italia suggeriscono spesso di
utilizzare delle farine che io
sinceramente non ho ancora compreso, tipo
di riso glutinoso, ora non so se siano
o no la stessa cosa, fatto sta che
quando vedi in video alcune ricette dei mochi
quello che tu vedi è una roba
giallastra, in realtà dovrebbe essere
color...Come si dice s***** in maniera...color perla - Ah s*****! (E)
Un liquidino perlato...e infine gelato alla
vaniglia. O yes!
La prima cosa che bisogna fare è
creare l'interno...una vaniglia deliziosa
Più che altro scusate ragazzi che è brutto
da vedere in camera che c'è tutto questo
capito, che strasborda - Eh infatti, ci penso io - Eh no...
- Ma è buonissima ragazzi! (E) - Vero? Com'è che si chiama? Gelato alla vaniglia biologico
"Gelato alla crema" (E) - Tenente Dan gelato alla crema
- Gianmarco! E' un elefante - Non è vero, sono un mochiko
Per prima cosa prendiamo un vassoio e li
mettiamo sopra...un mochiko. Innanzitutto
vorrei ringraziare emmymadeinjapan
perché è la ricetta che noi stiamo
seguendo. Usciranno enormi, che buono!
- Quello è il mochi (G) - Ma quello è un mochi? (E) - No, è
una palla di gelato. Vado a buttarli in freezer
- Gu stai facendo lo schifo! (G) - Guglielmo! (E) - Madonna! (E) - Io adoro il gelato
- Va bene qual è la parte successiva? (G) - Buttare la
scatola
Non ti azzardare mai più! E' arrivato il momento adesso di
fare i mochi, all'interno di una ciotola
che possa entrare nel microonde...Da quant'è
che non mettiamo nel microonde una cosa?
- Da quant'è che infatti andavano bene le ricette? (E) - E non eri stufo?
In realtà fare i mochi è semplice ma difficile
Di questo, mochiko,
io vi lascio il link per comprarlo in
descrizione, è una farina di riso dolce
ed è quella che viene utilizzata per
fare...gli starnuti, ma mo te inizi. Per fare
i mochi. Io non credo che altre farine
possano andare bene perché ho visto
veramente dei mochi che alla fine facevano
schifo - Che cos'è? Ah il mochiko, vero (E) - 75 g di mochiko
alla vostra - Ma così quanto impasto hai?
Per quanti mochiko? (E) - Non ne ho idea
- Cioè per tre dovrebbe essere giusto? (E) - Si ma abbiamo fatto tre mochico così
100 g di zucchero - Ma sono dello stesso colore, lo zucchero e il mochico? (G)
- Mamma mia questo qui... - Ma lui, il mochibo, il mochita
Lo zucchero è granulato mentre invece il mochiko             - Mochikò (E) - Il mochikò è un po tipo zucchero a
velo. 100 millilitri d'acqua, arriminiamola. Vedete che cosa avremo
alla fine? Enrico avvicinati cioè...metà uomo metà sedia
Shaka shaka shaka. Sbattiamo a 600 watt per due minuti all'interno del microonde. Poi preghiamo Dio
ragazzi - Ma scusa metti la pellicola nel microonde?         - Sisi può andare nel microonde questa
2 minuti. Gianmarco, quelle gambe da Jack Skeleton
In realtà suggerisce di rimetterlo altri
30 secondi. E' uguale giusto? Quindi io
saltiamo - Non credo sia così - Si è così, grazie. Vedete com'è? Prendete l'amido di
mais e lo setacciate su un tagliere. Shaka shaka shaka
Mi sono dimenticato come andare avanti - Comè? (E)
Stranissimo al tatto...Lo raffreddiamo per
una trentina di minuti
Allora un'oretta - Il grembiule (G) - Il grembiule!
- Non hai fatto nulla di speciale (E) - Avremo davanti
questa sbrenfa e dovremo tagliare i
quadratini con i quali avvolgeremo il
mochi. Prendiamo un piattino, gli mettiamo
sopra della pellicola trasparente e
tagliamo...C'è qualcosa che non mi torna. Guarda che bello! Togliamo gli eccessi, mettiamo l'ultimo
foglio di pellicola e aridaje, lasciamolo
riposare altri 40, tiè! - Una ricetta secolare! (G)
- Madonna dillo però! (E)
- Vabbè è come fare la pizza - La pizza la fai in un attimo (E) - No perché deve lievitare
Guarda, la sua faccia in questo momento è così
Vabbè aspettiamo il tempo. Passato il
tempo andiamo a tirare fuori il gelato dal
freezer e i foglietti dal frigo. Allora
questo qui si è poco, mezzo sciolto
morto poraccio. Qui dobbiamo essere
veloci perché l'estate sta arrivando e
quindi questi si scioglieranno in due secondi
Afferriamo un foglio, afferriamo il gelato
e lo avvolgiamo. Per darmi una mano
consigliano di prendere la carta, questa qui, pizzicare i lembi in modo da
chiuderlo alla perfezione - Guarda che carino che l'hai fatto (E)
- Adesso improvvisamente curioso? Capisco che
quando lo Chef bravo... - Ti fa venir voglia - Di
mangiare anche la me...Allora questo è il più storto di
tutti, preghiamo Dio che funzioni. Ragazzi
indovinate un po' che cosa succede adesso? - Che cosa (E) - Lo infiliamo per un'oretta in frigo. Ragazzi
quanto mi piace il gelato
Abbiamo aspettato una mezz'ora ragazzi, perché un'ora è troppo - Gu non so molto dure ste cose..senti (G)
- Grazie! Allora ok, quindi dovremmo mangiarle velocemente. Iniziamo ad aprirlo...Che carino!
un po' diciamo rimboccati sotto, diciamo
il mochi più bello è quello liscio liscio liscio
- E' carino eh (E) - Sono un po' mollicci, un po' mortizzi
Venite ad assaggiarli, io li adoro - E' un po' appiccicoso      - Sono appiccicosi - Gianmarco si è
Buono. Vabbè nel senso è un ripieno del gelato che amo comprato più
gli hai messo sta cosa attorno. Cioè praticamente non ho fatto niente, questo
stai cercando di dire? - Questa è una ricetta
giapponese? - *incomprensibile (E)
- Caldo?
- Bocca in ipotermia
- Che succede - Eh sta congelando - Il cervello? - I denti, è una brutta sensazione. Un Estraneo! - Il gelo!
- Ne vuoi un altro pezzo? - No no no. Brr - Son buoni - Dai è un buon dessert - Cioè è particolare, nel senso
un impasto mai assaggiato prima - Cioè ragazzi dopo
due generazioni siamo riusciti ad
assaggiarli, discreto - Sì esatto, diciamo che l'attesa non vale
il risultato - Non sono assolutamente
accordo, vi porterò a mangiare dei mochi
magari fatti ancora più...Sento un leggero
sapore di farina, che è eccessivo - No c'è
qualcosa di tipo granuloso - Non ci doveva
essere - L'impasto che hai fatto non era male. Com'è
che l'hai definito prima? Perlato - Perlato, il colore è giustissimo, il colore
è perfetto. Secondo me o era un po' troppo amido di mais o un pochino troppo farina
Vabbè comunque siamo arrivati alla fine
di questo video ragazzi, fatemi sapere
se proverete anche voi a fare questi
mochi - Vi ricordo che su Instagram mi
diverto sempre a vedermi taggare
all'interno delle vostre stories, delle
vostre foto, quando ci provate a fare
queste cose qui, spesso i risultati sono
anche peggiori dei miei ragazzi.
Come sempre vi invito a iscrivervi a
questo canale se vi siete divertiti, ad
attivare la campanellina delle notifiche
qua sotto per non perdere i prossimi
video. Noi come sempre ci vediamo la
prossima domenica alle 12 con una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata. Ciao - Di Cucina Buttata
-Cucina Buttata. Ciao...Oh è tutto
buttato qui, anche il mio tempo